dr kowalski prepared three copies of the  february 9 2016 edition of the new york  times for testing a copy was placed on  the setting one to one and the output  produced was one copy of the february 9  2016 edition of the cleveland ohio plain  dealer another copy was placed on the  setting very fine the output produced  was a copy of the february 10 2016  edition of the new york times an  examination of the paper revealed large  blank sections and the final four pages  were completely blank the texts  consistently changed while being  observed prompting researchers to  hypothesize that they were seeing the  draft of the issue appear as it was  being written